I was manufacturing the firearms on the
ammunition or having a gun a full Chief
because if anyone give me [ __ ] obviously
it could end up coming now I end up
shooting someone in bed now then Lisa
will think it was what it pulls out the
weapon he said what are you going to do
with tassel I just thought you know what
[ __ ] I just woke up away in the mood
so I shot him well lucky by God's grace
he never died because if water went
through [ __ ] a bit to the left he would
have been dead
where a young kid was shot and I think
that was the turning points I mean life
when I thought now you know what the
folks happen I knew about it before and
it never bothered me but when you watch
the program
see his parents and
I know a lot of people don't believe me
and say oh no that's [ __ ] you you
know you've got no one feature why would
you be brought about Apple something
clicked when I watched that program that
was televised I knew about it never
never faced me it didn't bother me it
was just collateral that I used to
review that as collateral damage and
then when you watch the program and she
did
parents went through and his family
I used to put hundreds and hundreds of
weapons
on the street probably bought over a
thousand weapons I didn't keep
calculating of how many it was but
probably put over a thousand weapons on
the streets and even though it went my
weapons die
during my crime
still you know imagine what are the
crimes and I thought no that's not it
it's going to you're peddling evil
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anthem has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life reg are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallet that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Richardson much great
guys are going to give you 10 off and
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
that's ridge.com forward slash trigger
and use our special code which is of
course trigger
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantin Kissin and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
former gang member who's now working to
get kids out of gangs to Karis McGrath
welcome to trigonometry all right how
are you okay it's good to have you on
man uh before we get into uh various
stuff we want to talk to you about
obviously crime prison uh stop and
search a bunch of other stuff uh but
tell everybody what your journey through
life has been because it's unlike pretty
much anyone that I've ever met frankly
it's a bit of a colorful past
um the age of 15 I got involved in Patsy
crime from the age of 21 that escalated
the gangs and Firearms weapons
um and then I got eight year prison
sentence in 2004. the firearms and uh
are shooting and then I was released
2009
um
I got a gang in Junction put on me in
2011 by myself please then 2012 I moved
to Lancashire to get away from the
gangan junction
um and they put an operation on meat
longship police I think in 2014
2016 I was arrested by Langston police
and I was jailed for eight and a half
years uh later on that year
and then I was released in 2020.
so I've saved to I've saved another
small few prison centers for Patty crime
when I was a couple
uh I've saved two significant ones
see you were in prison two years ago
um just over here I was released in July
2020 yeah yeah I was released from open
conditions whereas on me pre on me first
sentence so I was in high security I was
in category
on on that one and coming back to the
beginning you say you got involved in
petty crime how does one get involved in
petty crime how does that happen I think
it was me upbringing
just the earlier was leaving me pierce
the people I was around you know
everyone I knew back then everyone I'm
mixed with every single person by one
um went on totally the life of crime
went on to prisoners and there was one
uh there was one Jewish guy got a mixer
but then who went on to be successful
but apart from that everyone went down
to lose a crime and criminality uh or
the end up getting addicted to drugs
drug addiction or you know with certain
evidence that dimensional there's no
person that are mixed with other than
that one that's made a good
life for themselves
and do you think a large part of it is
like the area that you grew up in is it
the fact that a lot of these kids maybe
don't have dads in the home is this
something that you could actually cite
that is the one thing or is it a
combination I'd say It's a combination
of factors because everyone lived a
different life some people other dads
from people never some people were
parents were skins and he lived in a
smelly ocean people never bought you
know so Evan was different I wouldn't
say there was one factor but I think it
was a combination but I think it was
peer influence
is a primary factor in leading people
Australia like we started off on
motorbikes
and then we started I think I got my
first car when I was 11 I could drive
when I was 11 years of age I think the
first one was a Chevette Vauxhall
Chevette and I was so I was on the
street to 11 years of age I think the
first time I got arrested when it was
about 12 driving a motorbike 13 Maybe
um for you know that it just goes down
Spirals and then
that was that but did that not scare you
sakaris the fact that you were 13 years
old and suddenly there's a police
officer there that would put the fear of
God into me as a young kid no the first
time I got chased on a moped
and there's two of us on it but there
was a Vauxhall Cavalier that the police
wouldn't Yeah in our field and he Jesus
went even a Chase because we ran out of
the movement he was probably doing about
10 miles an hour so they just come
naturally and block this off and they
arrested me and told me the police
station and around my parents my parents
come and got me and that was that I
think I was too young I went like a the
police knew it was just I was just a kid
even though I was anti-social I went
really they were not on too bad you know
me
and you you say by the age of 21 you
you'd you'd progress to gangs and and
guns at that point yes Finance was I
went to a an area down South Olympia
um bought a loaded Firearms off with
these Asians revenue and then went back
to Liberal but that was the result of me
being bullied by
uh like a loads of dominant lip there
was a load of dormant bullying me
um
come back
and just that was that
now from there I just got I end up
manufacturing and distributing Firearms
selling firearms
so I think one thing is leads to another
but there's always like a Gateway
offense there's always a Gateway in the
ground
and man was Patty crime and then the
bullion resulted in me getting involved
in firearms and gangs for our fingers
primarily in in the first instance for
my own protection
and then it become a habitat and become
habitual or behavior like carrying a
weapon all the time a firearm all the
time
I was when I got arrested in 2003 and
there was a firearm actually built I
loaded with fire alarm next to me but I
was arrested in Grange Mountain
so it becomes habitual it become normal
for me to carry the carrier gun
sometimes I carry two I'll just say for
before you ask the question for answers
for we have a big American audience and
if they're watching this they're
thinking well guys you know we've got
guns but in this country having firearms
I mean that is a very serious offensive
it's I think it's five year minimum
sentence and and it is
it's rare fire Firearms are
common but they're not as common as
knives as such because they're expensive
to Pages the more difficult to Source
whereas a knife every kitchen has a
knife or I never use the cutting knives
I used to carry guns and that's what I
used to feel comfortable with I would
never felt comfortable carrying a knife
away from me well I used to you know I
used to get feel safe carrying a firearm
you use the word bullying now I don't
think you mean bullying how a lot of
people think about it where you get in
the for instance a lot of people think
bullying is people making nasty comments
to them not being very nice what do you
mean by bullying well bullying consists
of many things you remember bullion can
be in the playground or the bullion I'm
reference it was I think I was about
20 years of age at the time
and these group of men fully grown men
Dorman they're both free guys pulled up
to me and took my car off me then I went
and met him that night and they
kidnapped me and were trying to chop me
from off it was only a threat to scare
me but they put the [ __ ] up me I was
terrified there was petrified you know I
I wouldn't go out the door I was felt
suicide and I went to the police
remember it was a schuberty police
station and the police didn't give a
[ __ ] in other words they were saying you
deserve what you got your little they
never said that it were in their own way
should understand what I'm saying
because I I was a pest but I was only a
petty criminal very Petty Criminal and
as a result uh there is no one
academically so in the end as a human
being I was at cracking point and
I thought I'm going to defend myself
against these people
so we just went and bought glowed the
guns but I got different people to throw
in the pot
and then I I pitched them cheaper and
then charged them a bit extra and then
shook me on choked me off a few out of
it you know what I mean because I never
had the money to pay him at the time
in a way that I come up with a few guns
and then from that we went into
manufacturing them so we went into
making them deactivated them and would
reactivate them and make the ammunition
and which I don't got arrested without
in 2000 and
four I think it was and I ended up
getting eight eight years jail all
together
and how easy is it to do that to take to
that process because you've just made it
sound like it's quite simple is it
simple or is it actually does it require
quite a bit of talent know-how Etc it's
like saying it's building a house simple
to a builder and a bricklayer it's
simple but to me and you it's difficult
whereas manufacturing finance and
building finance and reactivating them
simple to someone that knows how they're
doing what they're doing just like a
mechanic it's simple to repair the car
but I can't repair the car if you
understand what I'm saying back then but
I I had my own Big Unit a big Factory
and back then I think I've done it for
three years
two three years it was it was easy but I
used to enjoy doing it so it means that
sometimes I do 10 a day sometimes I do
50 to 15 in a day it depends if you add
me on what orders they are but
you know it become
habitual but it all stemmed from the
bullion well I went a full show now I
was I was gone and he had to win I think
the bullion pushed me over the end it
pushed me over the edge with a
combination of other factors one
happened earlier on me childhood
the volume was was destroyed I broke
that broke the camel
that made me just go and and there was
nothing there in me as I never had no
rational thinking I was deluded I was
gone I was hearing voices I was
absolutely
I I was [ __ ] there was no part of you
that was sitting there going I'm now
manufacturing 15 Firearms a day now
sometimes it return always you know what
I'm just saying on average it was quite
a lot no what I'm saying yeah it doesn't
and the number is not what I'm getting
yeah definitely I've gone from I'm a
petty criminal to I went and bought a
load of guns I carry a gun I have a gun
by my bed and I'm making guns and
selling them like did was that were you
ever present to the scale of like what
yeah I was I was mixed up and I was me
and was gone it was deluded well even
when it's I'd be on the toilet
I just put the bullet in my finger
because we used to make the ammunition I
used to make the ammunition we had the
pressure as well so we put the powder
then we put the edge on the primers in
the in the bottom during so I was
manufacturing the firearms on the
ammunition but I haven't made gun a felt
safe
I'd go anywhere I'd go nearly where I
was dating a girl from uh back in Edward
and back then the bed and others just
want to thank me because it's from
Liverpool am I wearing a fighter so I
haven't been gone on me used to making
me comfortable to go in wherever I want
to go because if anyone give me [ __ ]
hopefully it could end up coming now I
end up shooting someone in bed now then
Lisa will think it was uh end up
speaking to him afterwards and
apologizing a couple of while I was away
I spoke to him on the phone
um a guy called Gareth I don't want to
give a [ __ ] her name but it was a guy
called garafu went to jail for I shot
him and uh finger went through her
shoulder and out of his arm or somewhere
in that area
foreign
I went to jail for shooting him and the
girl I was with at the time ended up
dating him while I was in jail it was a
bit of a bizarre one you know she
stopped coming up on the visits and then
one day a ranger
um and she's in bedroom and I spoke to
him and said put him on and said look
you know what's that and what's that he
he confronted me initially he came and
two of his friends confronted me they
Disturbed the tire on my car
the weapon he said what are you going to
do with tassel I just thought you know I
just woke up away in the mood so I shot
him both Lucky by God's grace he never
died because if water went through [ __ ]
a bit of the left he would have been
dead so I think it was you know it was a
blessing in disguise that I got that
prison sentence then because
if I never went to prison when I did 100
would render killersman yeah it was
another time when I went to Wade Smith
in town
and you know I was wanting to see these
Dolmen and I wouldn't afford twice about
pulling my guns on fire nothing
and I could have hit seriously hit or
killed innocent people and you know I
think back in retrospect the I think
Bachman think
I was glad that I went to prison when I
did otherwise I could have killed
someone or multiple people so but when
you're involved in that you don't think
you're not thinking well I certainly
definitely wasn't thinking straight
thinking rationally
[Music]
so if the police stopped me they
obviously they wouldn't find it remember
it was
a it was a bad time in my life I was I'm
always doing wrong but
I went and sentence that it aids anyone
innocent people it was just
unfortunate that the guy this Gareth guy
with his two mates was he's been on the
piss he was drunk he's seen me obviously
didn't like me because it was from
Liverpool Stadium
we should unfortunately
he said what he said and that was that
and I went over to try and speak him out
of it just said give it a miss the next
thing he's confront me so you know I
responded wrongly I went right what I've
done and regret what I've done but
I'm just I'm just glad they never died
you sound the way you talk about it as
if you incredibly paranoid do you think
that's a lot of a reason why we see kids
younger and younger particularly in
places like London carrying knives it's
because they're all terrified
yeah but even
I wouldn't say I weren't scared of
death from the enemies I was I I I was I
was more scared of not having none if
you've got something
like when I had the firearm for example
it I'd feel safer wouldn't fear not no
wouldn't feel deaf I wouldn't I'd fear
the police don't get me wrong but
when you've got that gun you don't fear
death even though there's still a risk
you can be killed you don't foresee the
consequence and without that you're
[ __ ] yourself so I can imagine
applying the same logic to the kids who
carrying knives
then obviously I think a lot of the
markets if they see a rival of this year
because a lot of them can't fight I was
the same so they can't fight so that's
why a lot of them carry the weapons
because if they haven't got that weapon
and they come across their enemies then
they're in trouble so the fear is you're
going to be on unprepared if you're
unable to defend yourself yeah something
along them Elijah that's right and then
there's different methods of protection
some people
unaffiliated The Gangs what do you think
these kids are thinking everyone else is
cutting a knife
so I want to carry one because the
description is the ones who were
Affiliated to gangs and they've got
rival gangs and they think if you
haven't got my knife on me or my gun
whatever the carry on
then they're going to be in trouble if
they come across the rivals if they come
along across their adversaries I mean so
I'd say a vast majority
carrier for self-protection
from whatever reason because they've got
gang rivals or just because they feel
scared and or vulnerable there's
numerous factors but a lot of it does
built up it's a protection
and how did you get involved in gangs
specifically were you like a leader of a
gang or not initially no I I initially I
clinged on to a gang that were fighting
with the Dormer strike shoulder clinged
onto them I was getting to touch them
and then end up selling a few of them
guns so they weren't great ones that I
was selling they would they were just
cheap shitty guns but they were still
powerful we used to test them on
containers and cars and the metal
containers on building side too putting
those in them new putting oils and car
doors so you can imagine what they're
doing to the body if you mean
did you did you never think about
when you were selling these guns on no
obviously you know they'll be used for
protection most of them won't be used
but you use one yourself did you not
think hang on this could be used to kill
someone here no I didn't I didn't think
like that don't get me wrong there's
once or twice when someone went they
wanted the gun to go and do something
and I thought no I don't want to get
into [ __ ] her and they're like the
weird occasions when it refused to sell
a gun someone if I thought even though I
will win asked about who was it and what
was if I thought someone was gonna be
like
assassinated with a gun I wouldn't that
that was a bit too much now I didn't
want to go to that level do you mean
because even though I was Reckless I
didn't ever want to kill any enemies or
these Domino didn't want to kill them
but I was just Reckless I couldn't have
done it through my own recklessness the
intention was to ever see them I'm just
going to shoot them in the legs or shoot
them in the stomach and we know that
that one on the list I wish I shot him
near the chest area but I just woke up
and we're thinking straight so it would
have been recklessness more than malish
or intense that it would have end up
killing someone you know what I mean
yeah so it was looking back it was scary
it was massively scary and I think to
prison
even though my first sentence didn't
rehabilitate me I think it was necessary
100 because it was gone where I was
getting worse and worse and the more
people you shoot the more confidence you
become as an individual as a shooter it
becomes a more common a common practice
I mean it's just like a fighter the more
people you beat up with your fists the
more confident you're going to be in the
more willing you're going to be to have
a fight you're not the more you get
self-confidence I mean and that's how it
is definitely with guns 100 I want to
get to prison in a second because we
really want to talk with you about that
but before we do just just take us there
chronologically so yeah you you get
involved with this gang because you've
been bullied by these door men you've
got guns you've sold them guns how do
you then get more involved in the Gang
yeah and then once I've established
myself to an event to call me on where
I've become like a loner and then I was
I was linking my Asian gangs and black
gangs in the silver in the south of the
country so and then there was all
different gangs coming to me to purchase
Firearms so Tana was Affiliated to from
just being clinging onto one one gang in
Liverpool at the time he was the biggest
gang in the city
they were a serious group of individuals
and I cloned onto them I went high up in
that young I was just a Klingon because
your enemy is my enemy but we have
something in common so and that's why I
clung onto them there's a fourth day
fighting against these Dome
so I need the Klingon to them so I'm not
a meal and then once you become more
confident and more established than
myself
I wouldn't really asked I didn't really
need them as much
yeah because then it developed me
confidence so I was confident standing
on my own two feet
and you were selling guns to all these
other gangs at the same time the vast
majority of people who there was a
couple of times when I refuse to sell
people fight arms because I thought
because they told me what they're going
to use before and I thought now I don't
want to be involved in that and I don't
want to take you know it's so I said no
it's enough for me but vast majority if
some if someone just comes to me and
asked for a gonna tell them
or they end up getting the rest of the
police put an operation on me and
dearest means for manufacturing and
selling guns in 2004. yeah we'll talk
about that in a sec how much how much
would you be selling these guns for
back then
the sentences for firearms were low it
went a five-year minimum it was like I
know there was a people outside clubs
that were getting liquid guns and
getting two years
you know what I mean so it was a low
sentence for gunstan back then I got
four year three months
and for a firearm and that was a big
sentence for a gun it was big yeah and
plus a wonderful children
it was the main judge in an appeal Crown
courts Henry Globus sends me and he was
very fair at me because he knew he was
just a deluge a kid he'd run off the
rails and he had serious mental health
problems I was bad
um a psychiatrist on a report from me
and I I went there I mean I was
absolutely gone on the edge so yeah I
got I got a big sentence for for the
fire ants but at the time uh if he was
doing 10 I'd do time for three grand for
example so we have 310 firearms for
three grand 55 yeah for three thousand
pounds 300 quid okay for one firearm
yeah but but that was in Bull yeah I
mean whereas these days the prices come
right up yeah whether it's back to
anywhere is expenses you could get an
after you handgun back down for like a
grand 1200 quid 1500 Quit match whereas
now the prices are like three grand two
and a half grand three Grands things
like that that even
years ago the price went right up do you
remember back then it was and most of
the ones I were doing would reactivated
once the vast majority of guns I put on
the street that sold were all
reactivated so do we do pennies the
Bible we're buying them for like
60 degrees 80 grit 90 grid it saved me
half an hour to reactivate one but we
change the battle
and make the ammunition that was a it
was as simple as that right and so you
were rapidly turning over all that money
so you were making quite a lot of money
at the time then I was making quite a
lot of money yeah but I was I was spend
as I was you know we had to rent some on
the units and and the factories what we
had
I have my house renter I was buying
stupid little motorbikes and
I don't know how you spend a lot of
money on food eating out all the time
[Music]
exactly when he was talking about the
price of guns I'm like [ __ ] me
inflation's affecting everything but but
sakaris
so you you were going through that and
you had these psychological problems and
so would you mind just talking about
that a little bit like how bad were
things for you you said you were hearing
voices was that bad it was I was bad on
a scale I wanted to and I think it was a
nine but the judge recognized that and
sentencing me
um the two guys who got Nick I mean
David older they were in the 50s and
stuff like that they got no good about I
might be wrong on a number here but I'm
sure they got Nick combined so they got
they've got about 35 arms roughly
activated deactivated whatever 35 arms
and paraphernalia and so on take off
five years and five and a half years I
was a kid and got four year three months
yeah so in comparison I got a harsher
sentence
I mean I think the Judge who sent me on
the guns was David Bolton but Islam me
more than them for one gun of a
manufacturer and I go four or three and
I was deemed to be low down the rank I
was just a kid with bad mental health
problems and they were two adult men it
would order them from America
they went on a bigger scale and they
only got around the same sentence as me
so you go to prison and the vast
majority of people who watch our show
and listen to our show have no idea what
prison is like tell us what's it like
that Journey your first day
well well for me because I upset that
many people but this is in 2004 I went
to prison first prison I went to was
Walton in 2004
when I got nicked on these gun charges
um
when I went to prison I had every day
was a nightmare in Walton prison because
he upset that many people
it was all drug dealers and criminals
very upset I never upset your normal
average Joe public it was drug dealers
criminals and you know I hope shot that
many people how do you mean when you say
you upset them how did you upset them
um
watches one of the adverts they used to
have well I wouldn't say it was another
but you stood up drug dealers watches so
I would wait by the house
when they pull up I keep up keep up with
the car put a gun to them and take the
watch like the Roblox or whatever watch
that you mean so I I was dropping
watches off drug dealers do you own my
little from The Wire basically what's
that you haven't seen the wire
The Wire
you'd enjoy it yeah well you might enjoy
it yeah um okay so so you're robbing
drug dealers for their watches and when
you go to prison that's kind of what
happens slightly spoiler to this dude
I'm talking about in in the in the TV
series so you're robbing drug dealers
you're pissing them off obviously and
then you go to prison and they're all
there no not not that they're all there
they were still outside but they were
putting he was putting hits on me from
outside right they were bringing people
into prison you'd have mobile phones
back then in 2004 and they paid the
school just uh I don't know if I can say
his name on you a prison officer officer
Peters
he attacked me there was an
investigation so he was paid they were
influenced by these gunks you know what
I mean because he got me in the office
from machine so just to be clear drug
dealers paid a prison officer to attack
a criminal like you in prison yeah and
when you say attack what did he do well
it voted me in um he was saying there's
no guns in here you called me a [ __ ] bag
and whatever right but there's an
investigation into it and not another
company investigation was never
concluded well it made me life how
Peter's
um on another time they opened me to run
to London
uh about half six in the morning
someone come down with boiling water
but the officer the officer turned the
plans out of it I don't know what
officer that was I don't know if it was
Peter's or I don't know or you know it
was there was hits getting put on me
left right and Center because I was in
prison I was vulnerable but I always
swore when I get out I'm confused and
I'm gonna go out to take off and make
their lives or not every one of them but
I got a lot of them back you know what I
mean and a lot of them were from brittle
and when I got out of that um
sentence I I got a lot of them
to mentioned I I made the lives
difficult for I'm not saying it was
right what a dumbo I was just full of
haters and anger and I thought nah I'm
coming first I never done nothing very
depart from a lot of images of money off
and got compensated for what they've
done but you know it is what it is it's
water over Dutch brackets don't
people who told me younger forgive them
and after them are probably dead anyway
in jail whatever I don't know I don't
know what to reply
that was the past wow hey Constantine do
you want better mental health I'm from
Russia we don't have mental health so
how do you deal with mental health you
drink Vodka then go out and wrestle bear
if you live you feel better if you die
you're not real men what about the
Bear's feelings it's Russian Bear it has
no feelings people don't always realize
that physical symptoms like headaches
teeth grinding and even digestive issues
can be indicators of stress and let's
not forget about Doom scrolling not
sleeping enough sleeping too much under
eating and overeating sleeping too much
under eating this is Western disease
therapy has really helped me in my life
to concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my ADHD
and become better in all areas of my
life why is he telling them how weak he
is drink Vodka feel better better help
is customized online therapy to offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p.com
slash trigger
did you not see it as you putting
yourself in real danger that you're
gonna not only mugging people but
mugging drug dealers you must have known
that at some point there was going to be
retribution for that because you know
when you've got Firearms you feel
Invincible uh that's what like
when it didn't have nothing
I fear to even get in a slab
you don't understand what I'm saying but
when you've got that firearm
well I'm speaking like two decades ago
kilometro 2001 2002 gone back then
people didn't really carry firearms very
very rare
um and once she had that gun
it makes you feel invisible it makes you
feel like you've got a clove of
invincibility around you like no one can
harm you no one can do nothing and
because most of us 99.99 of the enemies
didn't carry guns I had the upper arms
to me so the result I used to go on I
was back then I was 10 Stone 10 a storm
with no teeth
and I I went to meet these shopping
Wirral I I've I've said a lot of some
fella this dog dealer and he's rented
these big studs these big juicets they
were like 23 Stone plus two brothers
um called Sean and Ben from from
birkenhead
and a vendor going on a meet with him by
this coffee of Legends I think it was
called later Street and will
and I pulled up
I I was in some stolen car and I had and
gone down my waistbands and I pulled up
I think I was like 10 stones and a half
Stone
a pair of shorts on with two pieces of
noodle legs like mileage like noodles a
pair of white shoe striped socks on
Mission thief and a vest uh I look like
a I look like a drug addict yeah just 10
Stone little snotty nose kid getting out
of the car it's a two big 20 freestyle
mint and I just went straight up or and
I wanted to put them on the back foot I
had the gun on myself they would have
done it
well it's put them on the back foot
straight away imagine you being 20 feet
Stone you and your brother two years are
absolute monsters
um everyone
strong and then some little chance going
standstone scruffy kid pulls up and
flies right over the years
the elements are surprising if they must
fall through to focus this Sandstone
crackhead coming up I went horrible to
them I just said you know what and that
was that it was put to bed but I'm glad
they never said that anyway because
that's the type of character I become I
had no fear when he had the gun on me I
didn't care who he was what he was
didn't come and meet you with me mate
said come on me on just with me gun
that's all I needed so I don't
understand why kids carry weapons
because it gives them a sense of
security yeah I'm not justifying it no
no no no I'm giving you the reason I'm
behind it based upon my past
understanding yeah well that's the
reason we wanted to have you on because
you're someone who's lived that life but
you've moved on and we'll talk about the
way you've moved on in in a bit but you
you get locked up
2004. is that good for you does that
help well in what my other as a life of
elbow one of went to Old cause I was all
right hooked to them and then from of
course I end up in high security I went
to the long Latin
I'm not you know that sentence and never
rehabilitated me but
it it done me well because when I got
out after that and since 2009 I took a
backseatened I went front line I went
flying around with guns all the time on
me I went because I'm talking about
cheetah sensors did knock me back a bit
so I went more organized more
more boxy type you know what I mean okay
and then what happens from there
2009 I was still involved in gangs and
criminality
in London and across the country Muslim
or Asian Asian gangs and black gangs and
then 2011 he put it a
a gang injunction on me meshire police
So eventually I've approached him I said
look if I move animation I couldn't be
more than three people at once I went
allowed with more than three people
um I'd come Army house in our fields and
the police should be videoing me with
video cameras not not covertly I mean
overtly a big there was a big van there
and they followed me with a video camera
when I was walking my dogs I was saying
[ __ ] off and then I went the Asda and
they're in the Asda they followed me
everywhere it was that that's how it was
a disruption tactic right now I'm you
know it was effective did they stop me
committing crime probably not both
combined with what they were doing and
then they put the gang injunction on me
that got rid of me out of the pool even
I would never rehabilitated me it moved
the problem
had a little pill and then I went to
langshita but when I went so long should
I become
more business-minded in a set of
businesses companies and I was still
involved in organized crime but it was
nowhere near on the level of what it was
doing it was worth wasn't firearm
related there's more
protection records extortion and things
like that and who would you be targeting
with the protection rackets and the
extortion
wealthy wealthy wealthy drug dealers
if you remember they went nationally
from Lancaster or added security
I'm we used to get a lot of legit work
jeremenko I can use the mediation as
well so if two gangs were fighting so
there was there was on one of the
mediations I think it got paid 10 grand
some of the others were five grand but I
was always against I never had money
because you're too big if you mean so
yeah and after that the blankship please
put an operation on me and I ended up
getting eight and a half years
for what
um I put off or run on a brothel
[Applause]
there was a black male where they tried
to recover 120 000 pounds someone land
someone they called defense and then
some 120 000 pounds
he would all Dodge you know what I mean
well
to come to court make up like the legit
and I I'm not criticizing them because
you know I I don't know
because you were blackmailing them yeah
right yeah I I I
used inappropriate measures to try and
recover the money yeah someone just
stuff I got accused of I honestly never
done I did I got accuse the breaking
windows and I never broke a window that
was me Cody you've done all that but I
got dragged into his
crap and of course the police wanted me
that much they were willing to use any
means to get me or a lot of the things
that vast vast majority of the stuff I
got accused of and I generally never
done it for
in 2016 even though went to prison
for things are never done
I think I got six of whistles and got
one guilty brothel yeah I played The
Guild to that but the blackmail
uh mostover was accused of it was Nicole
Davis doing that and why was the second
prison sentence the one that transformed
you the one that rehabilitated you or
helped to rehabilitate you obviously was
watching a program on Liverpool
um on occasionally Bill where a young
kid was shot and I think that was the
turning point
and my life when I thought now what the
[ __ ] you know what the [ __ ] happened
it was I think it was I knew about it
before and it never bothered me but when
you watch the program
and see his parents and
I know a lot of people don't believe me
and say oh no that's [ __ ] you you
know you've got no one feature why would
you be brought about Apple something
clicked and seeing a note and seeing his
parents and you think nah the [ __ ] that
went through
it was that was my turning point and
then you're talking about is it Reese
yeah I don't remember surname
yeah she was 11 years old yeah and he
wasn't involved in anything
but when I watched that program that was
televised I knew about it never never
faced me it didn't bother me it was just
collateral done I used to review that as
collateral damage and then but when you
watch the program and she did
uh the [ __ ] parents went through and
his family and yeah and you think
I I was I used to pull even though it
was years and years before
I used to put hundreds and hundreds of
weapons
on the street probably bought over a
thousand weapons out I didn't keep
calculating of how many it was but
probably put over a thousand weapons on
the streets and even though it went my
weapons die
crime it's still you know imagine what
are the crimes and I thought no that's
not it's called mature you're peddling
evil
I mean same same as when people deal had
when they're just peddling evil on the
streets and that's what I don't for for
years from 2001 up until May arrest in
2004. and you're putting that much
misery and [ __ ] on the street so it's
you don't know your victims are going to
be you know what I mean because
whoever's buying the guns they don't
tell you what the usual for because if
they did they wouldn't I wouldn't have
sold them
so they just buy them for whatever
reason well imagine how many people have
got armed and hit
as a result of me doing none hopefully
it just clicks and from that day
I just I changed from nothing not stayed
away but we changed with gradual and it
builds up on that and it was reinforced
by Charities engaging with me whereas
when I've listed the charity it reached
Jones's family there's a charity
connected to them
they've they haven't replied direct
quotation to someone else
and then they've responded and that that
gave me some motivation Jeremy and then
Motors against guns
responded to me when I read to them and
nah give me motivation to continue on my
path because they were they were
acknowledging me they weren't saying oh
no we got a piece of [ __ ] the misery of
course we don't want to know you or we
don't want to engage with you they would
acknowledge me even though when I work
with them when I got out he had to meet
with one or two of them but still at
that time it gave me that inspiration to
to push on on the right path you know
what I mean but if they never rip back
to me then
foreign so what do you say to a kid
because you know I'm listening to you
and I'm remembering me at 17 or 18 or
whatever and you're talking about well
you get a knife or a gun and you feel
powerful and every boy wants to feel
powerful and and able to defend
themselves when they're 17 right you've
got money uh you know you don't have to
take [ __ ] from anyone I wouldn't say
you've got money because I was always
scared right I was earning good money
sometimes but I was always going to
never had money yeah I couldn't pull
five grand dollars I couldn't pull ten
granddaughter but that's what some kids
think right you're gonna have loads and
obviously that's what they think but no
I've never met a rich gang member really
never not not once ever met a wealthy
gang member because Welsh
I know many wealthy drug dealers you
know but on Wealthy criminals but when
you're gang banging shooting at each
other on the streets you can't make
money to place it all over you you're
attracting attention and that's why a
lot of drug dealers are doing well don't
like the attention they don't like the
regular drama so they don't they don't
do all that all the big ocgs the vast
majority
don't get me wrong you might get someone
Shopper beyond the slide or to pay to
get it done for example it's they're not
running around gang banging they're not
carrying firearms gang banging on the
streets of Liverpool or the streets are
whatever City because they're focused on
making money do you know they're more
organized more better structured with
the gang mangas
they're the ones carrying the knives and
carrying the gungeon they're the ones
that never make money don't get me wrong
they might have a county line in the
maganda day but it doesn't last and I've
gone lunch over it they'll go out and
buy a thousand pound culture or
600 pound shoes and they've got a
girlfriend at home who doesn't work and
she's high maintenance because she's
gone for that type of boy that type of
lad so he's finally he's financing him
they're eating out all the time to
spending money stupid Watchers and
clubs getting champagne so
you don't really get many gang bangers
that are
high up in in that have got a high net
worth that makes sense but what about
the other stuff you know I I want to I
want to be powerful I want to defend
myself like that what you mean to talk
them out of it yeah well how do you
because that's one of the things you
work on yeah definitely as I say
professionals
all these
um youth workers now
do you think I'm too controversial but
one of my arguments to every
professional and every youth worker your
approach isn't working
so I'm probably the most controversial
reformist there is you know what I mean
because I speak to them like I was at a
center once and I called one of the kids
a little bastard
you know what I mean and I got frowned
upon all the youth workers were like oh
we don't want you back we don't want
your back but they're approach ain't
working and I told him I said you're
approaching we're not saying okay they
were called the little bastard
he's asked me ever since so I want to
work with him I want to work with him I
want to work with him because he he was
attached to me he wanted to work with me
he wanted to engage with me he doesn't
want to get he's got a piu alternative
provisions of people referral unit so
he's been expelled from school
no one can manage his kids no one can
control
but he wants to work with me even though
I'll call him a little bastard but these
youth records these two you've got the
youth Racers who haven't got a clue
you've got no plate aggress burnist
everything I've learned is from a book
uni College whatever
and they can't control these kids but
they haven't got they don't speak the
same language it's just like an Arab and
a Jew one speaks Arabic one speaks
Hebrew you're not going to get
constructive dialogue
from the German and so you need a middle
person who can translate
Focus
so what are you saying what's the
approach that these kids need in your
opinion it depends on the kids are a
black kid in London would be different
to reform on a white kid than Liverpool
right we've got different ideology and I
know the goals and the targets of the
same financial and power and guns what
the status
uh that might be similar or the same but
the ideology
in the way the speaking in in the way
the it's different so the methods what
will work on a wider than liberal won't
necessarily work on a blackhead and
Beckham or brixen for example say so it
depends who you reform and it depends on
the approach you're going to take or
every kid I've engaged with every young
person have engaged with has always been
100 receptive and my
approach my strategy
tested that over the past I'd say the
past 12 months approximately
it's been tested on over 100 kids when I
go to youth centers to be like 30 gigs
plus and every single time my Approach I
know why I come across
it's been 100 receptive
right and so so what tactics do you use
the first time you meet them what what
do you do how do you speak to them I
know it's different depending on the kid
hopefully it's got to be isolateable
there was one kid at a youth center I'm
not a different new friends that I went
to here's a bar
and he pointed him out said he was the
worst one and uh he started giving me
[ __ ]
calling me whatever he was saying and
I've given [ __ ] back and said you
[ __ ] little places
so I've come across
I've used instrumental aggression you'll
understand what I'm saying and you the
the the the professionals do you want to
give where there was a
like that and walked away he was
laughing boy shaking his head so I mean
saying I put a challenge from kids from
13 years old I put you know the [ __ ]
wheel carry on you understand what I'm
saying broke the ice yeah and then I've
took him outside and spoke to him
and I was I spoke his language
and me communication with him he
listened to me and he apologized
what do you mean by you spoke his
language what is a smoker's language
like youth work as one
you'll never see a youth worker scenes
of a good you [ __ ] little prick I'll
put you in a bin you wouldn't even call
it yeah or a little bash door
they don't speak the language
yeah they don't go to profession they've
got too much accountability they've got
to satisfy these big wigs above them
knees and they don't come from because
even the ones in you're walking around
with the jeans by Denise and pretend to
pretend they come from not background
getting that guy and the kids see that
the fake the counterfeit the foolish the
full of [ __ ] excuse me language but
they're full of [ __ ] and it's just like
the youth workers some of them are black
and they think they can communicate with
every black kid that's [ __ ] that's
apologies because you're the same color
doesn't mean these kids respect you it's
just like a white youth where could I
mean every white youth where every white
kid is going to respect the white youth
with it and and I'm a massive critical
view of workers and professionals
because they've got the wrong approach
and I think they're making a problem
where's nourish how so they don't speak
the same language as the kids they
haven't got the right approach to have
them they're trying to pushy foot and
tiptoe around these kids and they go oh
you can't speak to them like that you
might traumatize them traumatizing the
[ __ ] walking around with an angle
and you're saying I'm going to
traumatize me you're [ __ ] Maddie he's
just he's just stabbed some other kid
down the road 10 minutes ago try and
you're saying I'm going to traumatize
them by calling them a little
so you speak the language and you assert
your Authority that's 100 yeah okay and
what else how do you get over the fact
that you've got a bunch of young people
in this country who don't have an
affinity to anything who feel like their
only way of getting success or status or
respect or power or whatever is to get a
gun or a knife how do you deal with that
yeah but look
if a kid says to me
I feel powerful when I've got a gun I'll
say yeah I agree because I did the same
and I felt powerful it's great it gives
you a push
and I can understand the budget again
however
it ain't gonna make you money
you might rub a watch or you might rub a
few hours of Cold Hearts from drug
dealer when you're putting your guns
from but you'll spend that and then
you're gonna go back out next week or in
a few days and have to do the same
eventually you're gonna get jail you're
going to be shot you're going to get a
five plus if you use the gun you get
longer but even if you just get caught
with you can gonna get five years plus
and you'll be shot in jail that's true
granddaughter what you've just robbed
off someone
if you sell a virgando 15 Zone 15 some
won't Rush your five years your postal
orders you can spend 25 30 good a week
so time's up by 52 maybe matters and
great where is it Jeremy through the 25
quid times 52
so do your sums so you're going to be
sat in jail skins on your Ash on the
phone begging your mouth for a post
loader I've been there myself
and it doesn't last that's why you see
all these gang members in jail the skins
and and a lot of them get onto these
young bro white [ __ ]
in jail like they'll meet them in jail
to Bear they'll be outside the gang
member will meet her and get onto her
through ranks where I don't know what
we're on the phone and they'll start
putting my money off it or get me
trainees babe I love you and listen now
so he's he's being financed by this girl
who is Matt imprisoned who he doesn't
previously know and she's got kids to
raise but this this gang member I'm not
saying all gang members are like that
but all vast big proportion do this the
cling onto girls because it's at the
source and then company shows their
funded from this innocent [ __ ] young
girl who's been
who's got misguided loyalty who believes
that this gang member in jail loves them
because he's on his Instagram with a six
pack and his chest out and he's got a
six-pack and he's in good shape he's
playing on it financially for financial
gain and then he gets out and and he
thinks enough okay she's got six kids or
freaking four kids and and she you know
I'm not gonna settle down with it it was
just a means to an end to get through
his prison you know what I mean to get
him Chinese to get him post lawyers and
that's quite common in jail kill me boy
gang members are asking I'm going back
to the story it's about re-educating
these kids on the consequences and the
pros and cons to benefits I'm not going
to tell any kid don't carry a gun
or I'm gonna give him
these the benefits these are the
consequences the consequences outweigh
the benefits but when I'm communicating
with them
I'm selling them straight look you'll
end up skins you'll end up in jail
you know what if you usually go and kill
someone you'll end up in jail wanking
for your next 30 Years you'll be getting
out for all men's and Junior off your
neighbor it's not the place to be it's
not the place to go with [ __ ] you know
if the benefit outweighs the risk then
fair enough for in this in violent crime
the benefit don't outweigh the risk
and it's about getting this message to
them and not saying don't do it I'm
working with the police or I'm working
with the council don't do it because
they're going to look at you like and
think why should I listen to you you've
got to put a few minutes you've got to
become
dear leader it's like a pack of dogs
and you're becoming part of that pack
you've got to become part of them and
then lead from within uh and and be a
good examples
on the streets for years whereas if you
go to UNI and hustle for three years you
got a degree you can go and get a job 40
50 Grand a year you're in a more
legitimately legit money than you know
from Quran are we going to buy a house
and he got what I'll just save up
save up from every week where are you
going to put your money I'll definitely
not to buy me I'll give it to me now
and then you've got to educate my money
London there's a there's a lawyer we've
got to program what I'm doing as a
lawyer who's going to come and do a tour
every program and he's gonna educate
them on joint Enterprise conspiracy
money laundering and he's going to
educate the reality
you can't just go and go and Rob people
or go and sell crack and then go and buy
all sorts of proceeds it don't work like
that you can understand what I'm saying
so it's getting the message
through to them
by speaking the same language and then
getting the lawyers to explain the legal
side
to corroborate what I'm saying look he's
a lawyer he represents
Stone Cold Killers he represents the
biggest drug cartel he represents the
west of the West these day defense it's
actually a very rational approach what
you're saying is you're not wagging the
finger and oh you naughty boy you're
going look you can do whatever you want
correct but these are the consequences
of interactions and they're not what you
think they're going to be correct and
and also at the same time giving them an
alternative yeah like the ones on the
programs when I'm starting the 16th to
19 year olds we're going to be
guaranteeing every one of them a job at
the end of the program
the 1250 is going to be two groups 12 15
16 to 19 the 12 15 we can't necessarily
test on an education it also ends up
provisions and prus so on so we can't
necessarily get them into work at that
moment
but we're putting them on the right path
we might get the [ __ ] a weekend
job in a garage or
open as someone's well electrician's
helper also you understand what I'm
saying but the old one 16-19 will get
limit to work and we're giving them the
alternative to their own legitimate
money where you can put it in the bank
you can get your good credit we'll teach
them about building a credit
and what you've got to do to get a house
what you've got to do to get Finance
what you've got to do to get cash I'm
going to educating them look you can't
just go into a showroom with 50 Grand
of dodging money and buy a car back in
the day yeah that was [ __ ] great but
you're in 2022 no don't [ __ ] don't work
like that we're educating them
what are you going to do with your money
how are you going to spend it are we
going to laundry are we going to clean
it it's not as easy as you can go up and
just buy a coat for you in your bed and
go to a club and Buy Champagne but
that's all your life is going to consist
of you're never going to have a house
you're never going to have a decent car
could the police are going to be
questioning and you can't just go and
buy a house like that you can't just say
oh man give me the money [ __ ] that
was something you've done in the 60s
it's absolutely bollocks [ __ ] don't work
like that it's getting this message
through to these goods and there's no
one in the country that's
got the solution
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
place your I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door
guys kids but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you thank you
when you get lost incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew doors
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share means have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
chorus do you think a lot of these kids
are in love with an image they've got
this image in their heads of what it
means to be a gangster and 100 look
and I know the feminist will probably
criticize me for this and he's [ __ ]
I don't know
these days if
if you're a heterosexual mom for example
or you like women for example just using
this as an example
for the kids to get a decent well I
wouldn't even say decent because the
girls would go for criminals are a bit
but um to get a decent looking one like
a fit bed as we as we describe it you've
got to have something to buy it no no I
know this is wrong but these kids are
seeing it I'm speaking let me let me put
myself in their perspective in their
shoes
no girl is going to look at me if my
[ __ ] [ __ ] working in McDonald's now
I'm not criticizing people working in
McDonald's so I'm looking at I'm just
saying this is how a kid is thinking
about this yeah look just say it how it
is and we'll we'll just in case you've
got any followers not working McDonald's
I'm not putting these people down we try
to have honest conversation what you're
saying is from this young man correct
he's saying well if I want to have an
attractive girlfriend correct I can't be
working in McDonald's I have to be
something yeah correct yeah yeah do you
want to create a reputation an image on
I know it's [ __ ] but they don't know
what's [ __ ] and most of the young
girls
not even the young girls even the girls
in in the 20s whatever 30s even the way
so much some of them are now do you want
that image they want that when they go
to a club
dear fellows this or their fellow star
or when they go out even the young ones
who were 14. my boyfriend or whatever
they call them in different cities my
fella
is such and such he'll [ __ ] kill you
or you'll do this he'll do that that's
what these girls want because then that
image what the lad's got then
goes off onto the girl so no one [ __ ]
with a girl and then she's air
credibility comes up air status crawled
up because she's dating Johnny Johnny or
whatever he wants whatever he wants you
know Tommy ten guns yeah he fellas told
me 10 guns so I'll do what the [ __ ] I
want she can speak to whoever she wants
how she wants because if anyone reacts
away
any of their peers give a [ __ ] a fellow
then they don't want the [ __ ] over a
fella so status
is a massive thing just if you're a [ __ ]
then then you ain't getting that woman
yeah you got I don't want to come across
offensive boy audition if you're the
[ __ ] you're going to end up with some
little spotty gimpy kill and who wants
to be seen by the gimpy kill
I I've got a gimpy girl now so
I shouldn't even called it up
she's a she's high up on a company she's
normal she she wears glasses she looks
like Harry Potter book I like her yeah
that's what you need in life he needs
one legit you know what I mean whereas
these kids don't want that type of stuff
they want yeah the Beyonce type or the
big booty the big legs and the and the
twerking and she's got loads of
followers on the [ __ ] what's that
thing called Instagram tick tock tick
tocks my Instagram followers and I've
got 50 000 likes on on me on me send me
a naked picture yeah that's what these
kids want status reputation so working
in McDonald's ain't going to get you
know status unless you go to flipping
burgers and you can flip a bacon in six
seconds and get an ultimately put it
it's bollocks and and so that's why
we've got to change the ideology of
these kids
that okay you've got this lovely looking
girl now but when you go to jail
she'll be [ __ ] your mate
trust me or or your adversity your gang
member rival or be around [ __ ] here
in your bed because that's the way
that's the way if you attract that type
of energy that type of person
then the outcome is always going to be
negative because if you can't sustain
there and maintain that woman in prison
if you're a good person working in
McDonald's you'll get a good woman
100 you'll be loyal and faithful where
if it's a woman who goes for these
little gang members and wants our status
that's all she wants
she likes the status and her reputations
the moment you don't have that she's
gonna find someone who's got it correct
and when you go to prison you're no
longer have to yeah because when you go
to prison people are like oh yeah
remember [ __ ] him now he's doing the
tent he can't do nothing to us so we
lose his influence he loses his
credibility and so on
what do we do now we can't protect me
when he's in prison he can
it's like the girl I was with at the
time when I went to prison for shooting
not love she ended up getting with the
ladder shot it was a bizarre State of
Affairs but I thought Michelle naranga
and he's there in the bedroom for a
month and a fourth what the [ __ ] am I
even doing I thought you know bygones be
bygones I apologize someone said look
I'm sorry for what I've done and they
explained me reasons and and he
apologized back to me and
it was walking under the bridge it was
it was done in Thurston I've seen him
since when a girls and you know a lot on
swimming that was that I never stopped
this program and we're never going to be
made for
you forgive me well he shall they
forgive me and and I generally apologize
and it was genuine
sakaris there's a lot of people who are
saying look the a large part of the
problem is you know drill music for
instance it glamorizes it the kids
listen to it look I don't believe this
but there's a lot of people out there
and this is an argument that they
consistently use and in the 90s it was
you know gangster rap what do you say to
these people well Prince Ali I'm sure
it's Prince Harry opens what's his
brother name Prince Francis
William William
one of the demolitions I remember one of
them saying they listened to gangster
rap or 50 50 pence whatever the [ __ ]
50 pence is such a [ __ ]
the American rapper you know yeah yeah
women in the club and all that type of
ship or one of them listen to him and
you don't see Prince Harry and William
run around London yeah with a Glock with
a mask on yeah it's [ __ ] but
rap music in itself doesn't
make people into a monster that doesn't
make them go and get a gun and go and
Rob someone
it just reinforces the ideology I'd say
it's still got to be there it's like
chlamydia
it's got to be there to spread it it's
got to be there to grow do you
understand what I'm saying if it's not
there
rapping rap music May enforce that
ideology
you know what I mean well
and I think the main issue of rap music
Club Music whatever you want to call it
is that
deflate each other so one gangle sleeps
another gang like one gang will say
rapping about what whatever he's rapping
about you'll go
yeah sorry tip shock your mum or or the
north jeep and whatever they're called
yeah
I [ __ ] your sister
you see where I'm coming from so it's
still got to be there where there's a
two kids you wear from McDonald's to
wrap and go or eat cheeseburger with
[ __ ]
I've got to be dead they've got it's
already got to be within them yeah but
rap music does it expedites
anyway yeah so don't think right it
might create rap music from my create
drama between true gangsters my opinion
poor typical rap music never made them
shoot him he would have shot someone for
a different reason
do you see what I'm saying so they're
already that type of character I guess
the argument is when you talked about
people having an image in the head of IT
reinforcement yeah it reinforces that
with the cars in the putting a video
just so reinforcing and and it gets the
image
out there the spectacles the cars the
women the dogs
the gold change the watches and and the
boys you're on a video with 10 10 of
your mates if they were happening about
being skinned and going to prison they
probably would have a different impact
okay if they were wrapping a bar skinny
jeans and belly dancing then the world
would be a great place but they're
rapping about their Lifestyles but after
these rappers who were doing their life
they've never lived that life they're
full of [ __ ]
and I think meter half usually would
there's one from the Midlands who raps
about this and I don't think what the
[ __ ] have you ever done you can't rap
about that [ __ ] because you're not in
you're not involved in the so the rock
on a bar for a 50 caliber you've never
even seen a 50 caliber you probably
can't even spell caliber do you know
what I mean so I have to move rapping I
just full of [ __ ] anyway but I wouldn't
say rap music creates
monsters I think
it can expedited situation yeah yeah
that makes sense yeah that makes
complete sense that makes sense
um so before we wrap up should we talk
about policing a little bit because
Prison and policing and all of that like
do we have the right approach to dealing
with people like the person that you
used to be in this country because
obviously in the end for you going to
prison for a second time did help you to
change your life and turn it around you
you might say well I was in prison yeah
watching that program and a few other
factors combined with that it did change
yeah but I think
but the same public at that moment about
stop and search
now my opinion
I used to get stopped more than anyone I
would stop I am response so I was
stopped 10 times a week some sometimes
five times a day in the building May
shot constantly by armed response
constantly by matrix
so I know more than anyone
how effective stopping Sages
thousands and thousands of times so from
2009 to 2000
2016. it was mostly 2009 2012 mostly but
I was still stopped after
sometimes three four five six times a
day so I know more than anyone
stop and search Jimmy and I can tell you
100 it disrupts it won't prevent you
being a criminal like I was a criminal
and stop me didn't prevent me being a
criminal but
it makes you more reluctant it makes you
more aware and when other gangs would
come from out of the way to meet me
it was I don't want to come across the
Matrix I want to avoid the Matrix I
don't want to do this I don't want to do
that so it does disrupt you stop and
search
is massively effective and you've got
all these MPS like
you know I I like some views David
lamiazbo and and Don Butler and things
like that but they're a gang stop and
search and the black community in
London's against them I'm saying
it's the black community of being killed
foreign
you need to stand up as a community for
example Regional plastic Community is an
example because a lot of them own in
London Fire stop and search like Lamy
Don Butler so on and the council is an
MPS but you need to support someone says
you need to support the police and the
same but it's racist and the stopping
black people I'm white and I was stopped
in Liverpool more than anyone I don't
think there was anyone in a country that
was stopped as much as me ASAP please
will notice so I'm not exaggerating I
was constantly stopped I was harassment
it was it was a proportionate measure so
the black community for example in
London
need to get behind the police
and support patient support stop and
search support disruption and if they
stop a blackhead 10 times a day
then if he's Affiliated the gangs
then it's Justified it's proportion
otherwise that's
deterring him from carrying and I'm
going
a firearm or perhaps a knife do you
understand what I'm saying so if any of
the London black community are watching
this they need to change that approach
their kids are being killed
and I don't even blame the kids I blame
the parents and I blame the community I
blame the impassion I blame the
counselors because they're all you know
do I love the police probably no the
certain police officers that I don't
trust to send police forces that are
doing trust there's someone like better
than others to remain I've had quite a
bit of support of depletions have gone
out so
it doesn't mean I'm procreation I love
the police but I'm saying from my
experience
and I think I'm more experienced than
anyone on this subject to say stop and
search works and there needs to be more
a lot more support for pollution now if
the police are stopping someone like
yourself 10 times a day whether you
white black whatever you may be and
you're not affiliated to Clan then yeah
the MPS need to come on down on the
police later on oblixton and challenge
them why are you stopping this person
he's not Affiliates that can't it's just
the odd stuff because you fit the
description or because you fit that
profile profile and as well works it's
massively effective like if I was
walking around the pool in a Truckee but
with a ball dead or a cup and the police
stopped me it's just it's tough [ __ ] I
fit the profile of the people who were
committing the crime and if an area in
London for example if it's black on
black crime black people are going to
get
and you need to accept that
that's one of the consequences
in order to reduce there needs to be
more stop and search and the community
needs to get behind it and that's with
any Community for my communities in
Liverpool uh I've seen one where someone
was getting stopped he'd probably run a
gang member by the Asda and the woman
ran over and grabbed the policeman all
right come on run on the finger
Liverpool's are totally different yeah
and one of the other things I want to
mention as well as
I I support stop and search and I
believe it's effective in Saving kids
lives saving the lives of young people
and reducing violent crime
so people need to decide what they want
the other one to reduce crime and
support the police individual War they
can be anti-pleasing anti-stop and
search and they'll continue to get the
results what they're getting which is
numerous stabbings numerous shootings
from more and more people if you're a
gang member
and your MPS
are going against stop and say a shotgun
is going to give you more confidence to
carry a gun or to carry a knife because
you're going to think the prospect of
being stopped is reduced as a result of
the pressure being put on a place now to
stop you do you see what I'm saying so
it's going to create more people
carrying weapons whereas when I was
involved in crime
being stopped by the police was a
massive deterrence in carrying a weapon
if you mean so um the only thing it
wants recovered as well I don't know if
there's anything else beforehand no I
was going to ask you something else
actually which is
you know we're having this we're really
grateful to have you on and and I look
forward to seeing how the work you're
now doing helps kids and all of that but
I just I can't help but think like we're
a first world country Britain in the
21st century it's 2022 and we're talking
about young people in our country
stabbing each other to death shooting
each other with guns like that's not
normal man it's not it's not normal how
do how are we going to solve that as a
society how are we gonna how are we
gonna get to a point where we're not
having to have this conversation look
you're never gonna eradicate violent
crime
you're never gonna eradicate a Bo you
can reduce it significantly and I I I'm
not just saying this and I've I've
sheltered this for over a year I
strongly believe I'm confident I've got
the solution not to eradicate it or to
reduce it significantly and it's aim to
the young people with the Next
Generation you've been involved in this
stuff it's not aimed at the older ones
because they're more harder to reform
the more ingrained that a behavior
becomes the more harder realistic
I believe I've got a solution but it's
very controversial it's something
different and it's something much
gonna attract a lot of criticism well
what I'm what I'm asking people is
allow it to take its course and look at
the end result
it's a means to an end the means being
used is massively controversial and
language used is
inappropriate it's not or all the people
I'm speaking to all are parents are
saying yeah this is what we need we need
this because this is what they listen to
do you mean the mentors that we're going
to be using and your average mental the
the I don't want to give too many
tactics and strategies away because
everyone says what's your solution and
I'm never going to tell them because
then they'll go and implement it
you mean like there's a guy who's doing
a program where I'm going to be doing
and he he's trying to replicated and do
it himself now but it'll never work
because he hasn't got what it takes I'm
not academically clever but I know
I can resolved this issue I don't mean
resolving the sense of eradicated
significantly even and I'm asking people
just to don't look at the means or the
tactics amusing and don't criticize that
look at the end result if I can
guess 75 percent of people on the
program if I can reform them have them
reformed then the means ought to be
irrelevant do you see where I'm coming
from what right sort of depends on the
news I suppose yeah and obviously it's
not going to be unlawful but it's going
to be a professional looking and go
put that hands up like there was one
investor that that was detailed
because
I called one of the kids a little
bastard
so he said no I I don't want to put my
name to the language to call them a
little bastard and I'm sure they've been
called where's me they're shooting and
stabbing people to flying around
McDonald's to taking people out of cars
at night points and you're saying
calling them a little bastard is
inappropriate the people normal people
and professionals youth workers
psychologists criminologists demand
their approach
if they've got the solution go and apply
it and and reduce the issue but they
haven't they're all scratching their
heads what do we do about life crime
well don't criticize me until you see
the outcome uh the program when I run
apart I'm trying to get funding the
Pilot's gonna cost me 12 000 pounds to
run for three months
and in order for me to get funded I need
to run a pilot scheme what I'm doing
what I'm going to be implementing and
get an outcome evaluation so what are
the results did it achieve the intended
results and how many people reformed and
I want to reform a minimum of 75 of
people that complete the program I'm
saying I'm giving them more or less
guarantee 75 percent of people who go
through this program and complete it
will reform will be reformed now I want
to run the pilot scheme in the city in
the North and it's
a
I'm trying it's 12 000 pounds of gun one
of the things that Donald set up will go
for me well people automatically look
and think go for me to scam ex-criminal
he's just he started using it I don't
know what they think I'm using it for to
set up another problem maybe which is
not the case for people automatically
assume the worst and it's not I've got
major scrutiny on me I've got a lot of
scrutiny there's a lot of guys watching
me so
if I was to fail on this program
then it's only me that's
going to get the battle I should
understand what I'm saying but I'm
confident that we have more than
confidence and that's what I want to try
and Implement to show
I don't want to be speaking about it I
want to put it into practice and get it
done and show and demonstrate and the
counselors I've spoke to the counselors
I've had a few meetings with different
councils
and they're saying okay yeah
if it works what happens
you know what I mean and then the
Thunder will come then I can go for
government fund and then I can go for
private Investments even investors are
saying there's many investors that
saying we won't put our name to it now
because we don't know the outcome you
know I I could go and get loads of kids
and recruiting back into gangs for all I
know or send them out on the streets got
loads of guns who knows
people don't want to take the risk in
you
until you see the outcome well yeah
you've got to prove it 100 and that's
what I'm trying to do so that's why I'm
trying to raise the twelve thousand
pounds already it wakes up less than 28
27 pounds 70 per good less than 28 pound
per day period and out of that money out
of that 28 pound to get in the gym
membership
to get in a personal trainer it's all
our activities covered it's the rent of
the classroom it's the workbooklets it's
getting them tuned from the classroom
event is covered in at the food so
they'll be fed as well so it's covering
28 pounds a day
is a minimum I'm not taking the wage out
of that no one's taking a wage people
are going to be volunteering but 28
pounds a day is going to be minimum the
lawyer who's volunteered and he's not
getting paid everyone's volunteering
their own time and
an effort to this program because some
people are confident you know what I
mean and I'm 100 that'll work that
there's no doubt about it I recruited
kids in The Gangs of radicalize kids and
another finger that happens to me I was
radicalized in prison
by people who are affiliated to Al-Qaeda
and that strategy what was used to
radicalize me I then went on to use that
strategy with kids on the streets and I
wanted to still continue to use that but
for the opposite effect so the what
you've got to do effectively is de-brad
the class kids
so did and they've got an ideology which
is ingrained in them you've got a
de-radicalize and change that ideology
change that mindset change that way of
thinking do you mean it's pointers just
put them on a program and keep them
manageable three months I wanna
make sure that when they finish the
program complete the program that
they're going to stay on that right path
and it's about changing the mindset
changing the way of thinking and you
know that's what I want to the tactics
and strategies while Al Qaeda used to
groom me
well one of the bonus questions we'll
ask for are locals only uh will be about
that yeah uh but for now we wish you the
best of luck with it we'll put all the
links in the video so that people can
follow up um we want you to succeed with
it we hope that you are able to do that
of course uh thanks for the time man we
really appreciate it uh before we let
you go we've got a couple of questions
for our locals only which we'll ask you
in a second but we always finish the
interview with the same question which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
um
use yourselves or do you mean Society
Society in respect of what crime what
anything anything you want to talk about
anything you want to mention I don't
know I don't really understand
instruction shares or the only thing I
do understand is crime and yeah so what
what don't people know about crime
prison policing that you think they
really should what people need to know
is prison
doesn't work prison is just a warehouse
what contains criminals so released it
does not work it does not rehabilitate
the prison can work it can be effective
if the approach has changed we're in
prison there needs to be effective
Rehabilitation but that'll take that's
another subject for another day
secondly prisons are needed to support I
support more prisons on longer prison
sensors but for certain offenders but
it's not working it's just a cons it's
just a university the criminal smoke can
go in a shoplifter and come out with a
drug dealer because they acquire more
skills and they make more connections
that's where I met a lot of my
connections in prison
um and the other thing is about policing
I think
there's a lot of police that I don't
trust to certain police forces that I
think are dodgy as hell but as a whole
society needs to get behind the police
they need to support the police and they
need their support
and promote stop and search or all this
[ __ ] that say no no we can't be
stopping these kids we can't it'll save
lives it'll save the kid's life because
if the carrying a good or a knife that
to that and increased risk of
Denby and harm themselves do you
understand what I'm saying so stop and
search
and an effective patient does save lives
100 and you know these people are
illusion kids left right and center and
losing family members Brothers fathers
if that individual that perpetrator
would go stopped by the police
then maybe the chances that he wouldn't
have went on to commit that measure or
to commit to assault where people are
seriously harmed in hospital so I think
Society needs to be more supportive of
the police
zakaris it's been an absolutely
brilliant interview if people want to
understand the work that you do if
people want to access the work that you
do where's the best way to find that
online yeah they can follow me on my
Twitter account and once the program's
implemented then there'll be all the
links yeah I'll be putting on none I'll
also send you the other links to to the
website to the to the company that's
going to be over overseeing the program
and implementing so we use Canada uh
when he's uploaded all the links to it
but people can follow me Twitter account
which is zacarius McGruff and I'll give
you the link to add to it but if there's
anyone interested in uh the contributing
to the program or investing in it then
feel free to get in touch with me
it's been a wonderful interview thank
you so much for coming on and thanks to
you for watching all our episodes always
go out Wednesdays and Sundays 7 P.M UK
time raw shows Thursday Friday and
Saturday and it's also available as a
podcast for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go take care and see
you soon guys
I was deeply deeply radicalized because
if I would never got out and went back
to gangs then maybe I could have been
the next shoe bomb with Richard
a plane down a chain down I I don't know
what what perhaps could have happened
[Music]